my name is paulie murray
and my field of concentration has been
human rights in a society dominated by
the ideas
that blacks were inferior to whites
and women were inferior to men
paulie was a writer a lawyer a priest a
poet
paulie murray was not just an amazing
lawyer or a badass feminist but also a
queer and non-binary person
[Music]
we first heard about paulie murray from
justice ruth bader ginsburg when we were
making documentary rbg and when we
started looking into paulie's background
we were just flabbergasted any
innovative idea
to change the world for the better
paulie seemed to be thinking of it like
10 or 15 years before it occurred to
anybody else paulie had definite ideas
sometimes
ideas other people disagreed with
paulie was way ahead of the times i
chose for my senior paper should plessy
versus ferguson be overruled my little
argument went to the supreme court
i was floored
that i'd never heard of pauly murray and
that i knew most people
had not heard of paulie so our approach
was to
not just find all of the accolades but
to really try to get it paulie's
personality
amazingly after production assistant
amira williams came across drafts of an
autobiography that paulie was working on
a close friend of paulie's was visually
impaired and so uh to get thoughts from
this partially blind friend
paulie had done 30 or 40 hours of tape
so we had this autobiography which was
so beautiful and then
we had this gift
of paulie reading it
in their own voice this is
chapter one page one
of an autobiography in manuscript betsy
west and julie cohen said to me
we have a lot of audio but we're not
sure how to tell the story visually
because there aren't many images of
these amazing stories that polly is
telling and i come from a background of
an artist i do collage art and i said
wait a minute we can build our own
visual language
and that kind of excited me because we
can really be creative with making it an
experience
as a cinematographer knowing that this
film was heavily based on archival
material i had really the conflict of
how can i bring any
mood to the visuals that would tie
things together and for me there was
like this whole idea of hearing stories
of people from the present time
connecting to paulie in the past
i went and read what i hadn't read and
then i realized oh my god
petersburg bus incident march
1940.
i did not start out to contest
segregation statutes there was just
nothing you could do but fight
paulie murray was the kind of person who
saw an injustice
and could not help
trying to do something about it the
scene where polly murray is arrested on
a bus for not giving up her seat to a
white person there are no images of
polly murray being arrested on that bus
it just doesn't exist
there was no movement at the time when
paulie was refusing to move to the back
of the bus holly was acting alone but
that did not stop paulie
this was
15 years before rosa parks
refused to take her seat in the back of
the bus
so
the challenge was we had this audio of
polly telling the story of the bus but
what do we see what is paulie murray's
point of view and what if we could be on
that bus
my friend and i
were
traveling from new york down to durham
to visit my two aunts for easter we
found this old promotional video from
greyhound that had just a whole journey
on the greyhound bus and so
we approached the scene that way of
showing passengers showing rural
backgrounds because of where polly was
traveling we wanted it to play like a
scene so that you feel like you're on
the bus even though you never saw the
arrest you never saw paulie murray but
hopefully
you felt it happen
[Music]
i maintain that the
the tool of
teachers lawyers
and ministers
is the same thing words communication
julie
stumbled upon a videotape at the
schlesinger library and even though the
quality was degraded we were so excited
it was very much our goal for
viewers to understand not only paulie's
accomplishments but really kind of feel
paulie as a human being i think that
having the audio tapes the videotapes
allowed us to present paulie as a real
person and we really tried to lean into
who was paulie
sit down lie down
lie down
wonderful
he has to be in everything
in fiction there's a certain level of
hyperbole that you could actually add to
the music whereas in documentaries
everything has to have an element of
truth to it so the music has to support
that as well i always think about
what piece of the story what piece of
the environment can i bring into the
score and in this case it was a
typewriter
[Music]
and i used it as a percussive element in
the background to move the music forward
but also feel very organic to who paulie
was
i think we're in a time a very
radical change
i do think that we're going through a
time of reconsidering our history and
that really connected us
to paulie's story
this story kind of allows you not only
to learn about this magnificent figure
in american history but also maybe to
rethink the way we think about american
history in a broader sense paulie murray
is the perfect example of a person who
should actually be a household name who
should be included in our textbooks but
isn't and it's not like paulie murray is
missing and then the story is complete
there are so many other people who have
made such great contributions who we
should also be including
when we were making this film i was
always considering the person who was
struggling with something that polly
struggled with so that they could
understand the fight may be different
the language may be different but this
isn't new and polly murray is a person
that changed the world
i'm hoping that as people watch this
film
they'll really get a chance to
have pride in what paulie did
but at the same time ask themselves how
can i do better we learned so much in
making this film we wanted to have
paulie's compelling story out there and
people to be fascinated by this person
we think of this film as the beginning
of a conversation let's like delve in
and start learning if this country is to
survive
we must live together in harmony
[Music]
you